das aus für die wiesn und auch immer
mehr volksfeste in ganz deutschland
fürchten natürlich darum stattfinden zu
können
ich möchte jetzt mit drei menschen
sprechen deren ganzes herz für die
volksfeste pocht die schausteller sind
und sich auf viele feste gefreut haben
ich begrüße ganz herzlich teenies vogt
sie ist in einem familienbetrieb man
basiert ein wandel bruder am hamburger
dom bereits in der fünften generation
bei uns ist auch marc roßmann er ist
chef des schausteller
schaustellerverbandes südwest und harald
kosik er hat eine sehr findige idee für
all die die volksfeste dieses jahr
vermissen werden herzlich willkommen
hinein ja zunächst meine frage an frau
vogt wenn sie so etwas hören die wiesn
wird abgesagt in ihrem fall der frühling
und der sommerdom in hamburg ist
abgesagt wie geht es ihnen mit dieser
entscheidung das trifft uns sehr sehr
hart unsere ganze existenz hängt davon
ab
unser ganzes leben findet der stadt ist
es nicht nur unsere arbeit ist es auch
unser komplettes soziales umfeld
es gefällt einfach alles weg für uns ist
so unheimlich hart wir wissen nicht wie
es weitergeht für uns herr roßmann wir
schalten in den südwesten von
deutschland wie sehen sie stehen davor
den karussells die traurig hinter ihnen
stehen und nicht in betrieb kommt auch
der cannstatter wasen
er steht auf der kippe wie finden sie
das
na ja gut ich muss hier natürlich mit
zwei herzen mit brust sprechen dass eine
schaustelle herz des verlierens einen
unseren veranstaltungen hängt ja und
jede absage ist für uns eine tragödie
ganz klar weil wir familienbetriebe sind
meistens mindestens in der dritten oder
vierten generation wenn nicht sogar
länger auf der anderen seite steht aber
natürlich der gesundheitliche aspekt und
wir wollen einfach dass leute gesund
werden damit alle wieder gesund sind und
geimpft dann geben wird auf die
volksfeste so wie wir sie kennen
musik auch sie möchte ich begrüßen sie
haben eine idee wie vielleicht man
manche menschen doch noch ein volksfest
feiern können in iserlohn zumindest
berichten sie uns wie man bei
feiern kann ja meine kinder hatten im
internet gesehen dass ein kollege aus
einer anderen regionen seinen mandl
wagen auch sagen hatte und die leute da
wirklich dieser wandel war sehr guten
zuspruch habe ich mit meinen kindern
zusammen gesetzt ob das war und aufgrund
auch möglich ist und wir haben dann ein
konzept erarbeitet und haben beim
ordnungsamt nachgefragt ob das möglich
ist und dann auch beim gesundheitsamt
uns erkundigt und haben dann ihr das
kind musste jan ammann haben wir gesagt
ist so groß und wir sind seit freitag
angefangen und steigert sie jeden tag
ein wenig vielleicht ist es eine
möglichkeit so ein bisschen sich über
wasser soll und er seien sie frau
funktion ist gerade gesehen sie sagten
für sie steht die existenz auf dem spiel
der haben aber den zum teil abgesagt ist
für dieses jahr wird es auch eine
möglichkeit für sie wird ihnen geholfen
wie blicken sie jetzt in die nächsten
monate in ihrem familienbetrieb ob das
wirklich eine option ist uns wissen wir
nicht für wohnen recht abseits
unser hof befindet sich in einem
gewerbegebiet ziemlich ab zum schluss
soforthilfen haben wir natürlich wie
alle anderen beantragt bisher leider
noch nichts bekommen was wirklich eine
option ist es für nicht wir sind ja zeit
relativ ratlos
die bürokratie in deutschland ich bin
mir nicht sicher dieses wie gut muss das
bei mir auf dem hof laufen das dass ich
mich damit über wasser halten kann
wir sind derzeit recht recht ratlos wir
sind optimistisch wir hoffen dass wir
wenigstens im herbst dürfen die
weihnachtsmärkte stattfinden dürfen
und sonst
wissen wir nicht wirklich wie es
weitergeht
herr roßmann die frage an sie was gibt
es für alternativen für den cannstatter
wasen wenn er dieses jahr nicht
stattfindet na gut in erster linie hängt
natürlich sehr viel am cannstatter
volksfest ganz klar es gibt einen
dominoeffekt andere veranstalter werden
nachziehen auch kleinere dorffeste
schützenfeste die ja eigentlich einfach
und auch mit bestimmten kriterien unter
beobachtung oder auffassung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes abhalten werden
könnten aber ich denke den stuhl wird
sich kein anziehen und wir müssen in
erster linie schauen dass das land baden
württemberg oder sprich eben der staat
uns hier unter die arme greift und für
uns ein rettungspaket stört weil wir ja
wirklich durch diese zwangsschließung
und unverschuldet in diese situation
gekommen sind wir haben gesunde betriebe
wir können ja nichts dafür ja bis jetzt
war alles in ordnung mein betrieb war im
dezember januar nicht irgendwo vom
existenzminimum zwar alles in ordnung
alles im lot bei der banken
steuerberater
so geht es ja sehr viel meinen kollegen
ja wir verlangen hier jetzt einfach dass
durch die zwangsschließung uns eben auch
irgendwo ein rettungspaket geschnürt
wird oder rettungsgeld wie auch immer
was jetzt sein mag dass wir relativ
unbeschadet aus der sache raus gehen
weil wir keine andere möglichkeit sehen
und ich denke auch nicht dass sich
irgendeiner weg sagte schuh anziehen wir
müssen halt einfach die zeit eben mit
unterstützung vom land überbrücken
können dass wir nächstes jahr in alter
frische weiter machen können oder
natürlich gerne auf den
weihnachtsmärkten ganz klar weil sonst
sehen wir die gefahr dass die volksfeste
so wie wir sie kennen keine keine
zukunft hat aber diese volksfeste stehen
und fallen einfach mit den alten
schaustellerfamilie die über jahrzehnte
jahrhunderte gewachsen sind wir haben
diese volksfeste aufgebaut und die
wurzeln der frauen sind es nicht mehr
geben wenn wir nicht mehr draußen ja
ganze generationen haben eben dafür
gearbeitet hoffen jetzt auf das
weihnachtsgeschäft herr musik ihre idee
ist sehr kreativ vielleicht können sie
uns mal genauer erläutern wie das genau
abläuft man möchte ja wenn man auf ein
volksfest geht vielleicht ein bier
trinken ein popcorn in der hand haben in
einem fahrgeschäft gehend wie
funktioniert das turbo
ja das ist ja jetzt karl den
kirmesveranstaltungen in dem sinne wir
haben gefragt was für auflagen erfüllen
müssen das heißt also wenn man zu fuß
durch geht haben die markierungen auf
dem boden
dass die leute auf diesen zwei meter
abstand einhalten können an den
geschäften sind überall
desinfektionsmittel vorne im
eingangsbereich ist ein waschbecken dass
man sich die hände waschen kann und es
hat im prinzip mit kirmes er nichts zu
tun nur das kind muss den namen haben
und dann haben wir nennen das mal grob
team ist so gut und die leute bin school
wir drücken all den schaustellern den
schaustellerfamilien und denen die eben
darauf hoffen müssen dass möglichst bald
weil wieder ein fest stattfindet die
daumen und ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für dieses gespräch mit hinein